moving from on-prem to the cloud can
bring a ton of nifty features for your
company and applications but one of the
biggest challenges and certainly the
scariest is how this movement can
potentially expose your systems to new
vulnerabilities and without taking the
right precautions you can run into the
risk of exposing your system in very
problematic ways so in this episode I'll
be covering how to control your traffic
and an out of your instances on GCP by
creating firewall rules once you
establish hybrid connectivity to Google
Cloud stay tuned
[Music]
firewall rules are extremely important
for a number of reasons
they allow you to isolate your internal
network and instances from unwanted
access they allow you to monitor inbound
and outbound activity coming from your
network for suspicious activity blocking
items that are considered dangerous
based on a set of security rules they
establish the first line of defense
against attacks viruses and malware and
helps create a secure Network so let's
take a look at firewalls
more closely in traditional on-premise
systems multiple servers on a single
internal network are supported through
the use of a cluster of firewalls
coupled with a load balancer a large
drawback of this traditional
architecture is that it doesn't scale
well in an on-prem environment a
firewall is generally a dedicated piece
of hardware that has an upper limit in
terms of capacity and this makes a
firewall a choke point to support
dynamic scaling you'll need to
habitually run down to the server room
and replace the hardware with ones that
can handle increased load of course this
creates its own challenge when the
traffic goes back to normal
you've now got a big piece of expensive
hardware going unused this is where
Google cloud platforms distributed
firewalls can make a difference Google's
global network has a federation of
firewalls that can operate and scale as
your systems need them so you only end
up paying for what you use rather than
making commitments for long term
expectations this gives you the same
power of your on-site perimeter network
which blocks all incoming traffic by
default but allows you to scale without
lifting a finger now here's the
important part
each VPC network functions as a
distributed firewall if you want info
on setting up the VPC check out the
first episode a distributed firewall
means that by default it will handle
filtering traffic but you need to adjust
it to handle your excess needs like
applying firewall rules to tact
instances in this example when a request
comes in from a compute engine system
labeled the red tag it hits the
applicable firewall role before being
allowed to communicate with the blue tag
while firewall rules are defined at the
network level connections are allowed or
denied on a per instance basis you can
think of the GCP firewall rules as
existing but not only between your
instances and other networks but between
individual instances within the same
network in google cloud a firewall rule
is made up of four things in action
either to allow or deny traffic that is
a rule can either allow incoming ingress
or outgoing egress traffic but not both
simultaneously
the type of protocol to which it applies
such as TCP UDP and ICMP either a source
or a destination for which the rule
applies this cannot be both as it
depends on the direction of the firewall
you create for example for ingress rules
you would specify the source which can
be IP ranges tags or service accounts or
combination you wouldn't specify a
destination because the rules already
being applied to specific VMs inbound
traffic you can specify the ports on
ingress or egress rules for example
allowing ingress TCP traffic on port 22
to allow for SSH access you can also
deny a VMs egress TCP traffic on all
ports for all destination VMs in an IP
range each of these parameters means
that firewall rules can help control
traffic to and from your Google Cloud
VMs accordingly let's look at what this
looks like I have two existing servers
here that are trying to use iperf to
test Network speed
here are my two SSH sessions with these
VMs with I per setup but note that I
have to use a specific port for it and
since that's not part of the standard
firewall rules it doesn't work
the only default firewall rules created
are allow egress and deny ingress
traffic and for Linux instances allow
SSH TCP traffic on port 22 we're going
to create a new
firewall rule that allows access for
iperf go to the V PC network tab and
click firewall rules you can see there
are a bunch of default firewall rules
created for the default Network we need
to create one for our custom view PC
that our instances are sitting in so
click add firewall rule create a rule
iperf access change the network to V PC
one leave it as ingress and change it to
allow the target tag will be iperf X us
source IP range will be the public
Internet the protocol will be TCP and
port will be 5001 to run iperf once that
saves go back to the VM instances page
and add the iperf access tag to instance
one
and I'll do the same now for instance
two
let's run i perfe ken
and boom it's working firewalls are an
extremely important part of your on-prem
to cloud transition they're the basis at
which traffic can flow to and from
individual cloud instances but also to
and from your on-premise network to your
cloud network if you want to learn about
more complex use cases check out the
documentation link below but to get you
moving on your migration to Google cloud
stay tuned for the next episode on
configuring IPs and remember optimizing
your network means freeing up your
bandwidth
[Music]